let's go to our caller from the 202 area
code who's calling today from 2:02
that me yeah that's you yo sup David you
know from this point forward I guess if
you recognize this moment you could just
call me Tommy Tommy they will enter that
into our system I just want to say as
well I guess they're discussing one or
two things the first thing would be like
how I avoided that whole right wing echo
chamber as you call it the YouTube space
yep
yeah and if maybe we got more time I
want to talk about squat but but of a
right wing echo chamber think I'm I'm
black alright I'm from DC okay so that's
typically speaking by default and it's
very less leaning you know that's kind
of the whole environment here but my
interest my main interest is video games
basically so much of video games are
kind of like influenced by interest
going forward like by taste and film my
taste in music and so forth but then
basically as we can I started seeing
certain types of commentators about
video games although I'm here and there
are a lot of them tend to get political
from time to time okay I think what one
of the ones that kind of resonated or
kind of like like I really started
liking becoming a fan of was this dude
named razor fist you familiar with him
no no no no okay so Evan was basically I
was feeding here's a lot of the comics
and a lot of funny stuff make a lot of
funny other videos talking that is like
kind of an edge lord kind of talking
about issues about all types of games
and culture and movies and such then he
also starts in political rhetoric and
basically speaking eventually I realized
oh this guy's a far-right libertarian
side dude he then started pulling out
support for Trump and I kind of started
by some of his arguments as well and
even was saying like they'll check out
stefan molyneux yep as some people like
to call it and honestly I was just I'm
like I don't have the time to do all
this other stuff because this guy is
just all politics
and everything cuz this is before I got
my political awakening I guess you could
say and what happened was and this is
how I got about to look away because it
was his other guy I'm just reading a cop
another actually know what happened was
I realized oh well I'm not used so I was
falling to do razorfish and then
eventually he ended up point out having
enough point out the exist that this do
name of jus tech was talking about like
Playstation next boxes and their lodge
and then I started watching his stuff
they used to also end up having like
beefs with each other later down the
line they squash it they doing her own
thing now somebody trying to bring up
old mess but review tech also end up
pointing out how he was a fan of Cal
kolinsky mm-hm and eventually I was like
okay man I would check this out but
again like Steven Molyneux looks like
I'm not really into political stuff like
this or so forth I'm like I'm hearing
this guy's stuff and I'm hearing this
guy's stuff but I'm just not really
feeling that gauge but then razörfist
got into a debate with Cal kolinsky that
was monitored by I think it was like TJ
Kirk I'm an atheist and everything yeah
yeah and so I watch that and I was like
finally I finally found like sometimes
political philosophy that I can have
with because God was just saying stuff
that I was like this makes sense to me
like straight up because I'm accepting
of the criticism said razors were saying
about like some left and like a lot of
the establishment circles but there's
plenty a lot of crap you can also throw
in at the right and now I don't turn out
this Tommy let me ask you this how old a
guy are you well right now I'm 26
yeah yeah yeah but this happened a while
back and everything god I think it's a
congratulations on avoiding the right
wing echo chamber or at least getting
out of it before you were you were fully
pulled in and hope it's not too hot down
there in Washington DC and I hope to
hear from you again okay all right okay
great Tommy take care of Tommy from DC
shot out of a cannon today